door breacher
trench sweeper
demon slayer
[Music]
from doom's iconic super shotgun through
to gears of wars nasha the shotgun is
one of the most popular and versatile
weapons in video games a trusty firearm
that packs a devastating punch
particularly in close quarters
but the gaming shotgun that we've come
to know and love takes a fair few shall
we say
liberties from its real world
counterparts shotguns and games have
been vastly over exaggerated frequently
granting players devastating one-hit
kills at close ranges before becoming as
useless as a chocolate teapot at a range
of further than just a few dozen meters
which suffice to say is not exactly how
they work in real life
so i've come here to the royal army's
museum in the uk to chart the
differences between a real shotgun and
its video game counterpart
[Music]
in one form or another the shotgun has
been around for the better part of 300
years in the timeline of firearms the
shotgun is a concept that has stretched
throughout a hefty part of history and
the idea of firing multitude of shots
from a single barrel actually predates
the term shotgun the earliest forms were
muzzle loaded firearms like the musket
and blunderbuss made famous of course by
the popular myth of fighters loading a
wide cone-shaped barrel with all sorts
of nails glass shards or even silverware
in reality you'd simply stuff your
firearm with a cluster of lead balls or
shot so evolve the nickname shot gun as
weapon technology advanced this nickname
became the de facto moniker for this
type of firearm the earliest appearance
of said name appearing around the 19th
century but it's a name that has
obviously stuck around throughout the
history of the iconic weapon the more
conventional shotgun the sort of
through-line development from if we go
backwards from modern shotguns 12 balls
or whatever 18th century you'll see
side by side double barrel of guns with
flintlock mechanisms on them and you
load them with a flask of powder and a
flask of shot of whatever size so small
small small shot for shooting birds
larger shot for shooting larger animals
simple as that and you would
build your load
in the gun and you would have a sort of
effectively a preferred recipe for doing
that for shooting different types of
game so a shotgun is literally just a
gun that fires shot but after a while it
develops into this whole specialist
world of firearms
in the real world shotguns grew into an
incredibly versatile tool being used
from anything from recreational sport
shooting and game hunting all the way
through into military use it became the
go-to weapon for 1800 stagecoach guards
warding off bandits and baddies trying
to plunder their cargo or horses
eventually this used creating the term
riding shotgun the shotgun then went
through many periods of militarization
like within the first world war where
the winchester model 1897 earned the
nickname trench sweeper or simply trench
gun for its effectiveness in trench
warfare resulting in an infamous point
in the weapons history where its use was
promptly protested by the german central
powers calling its usage inhumane and
prohibited by the law of war
so shotguns
are a massive family of firearms
obviously very diverse
and we've seen examples of all of these
in video games and movies but can you
take us through
what each sort of type of shotgun is so
starting from what's furthest away from
me there standard side by side double
barrel shotgun that would be
recognizable to someone from the 18th
century they might wonder where the
mechanism had gone it's actually now
hidden inside same basic configuration
nice wooden stock also breaking the
barrels doesn't just open it up to to
load it also [ __ ] the thing and then a
bit of leverage which by the way is when
when people saw these off to do
nefarious things it becomes harder to
load them it's not as easy as games make
it out to be is it
and then we've got the remington 870 the
the
archetypal pump action shotgun the 1950s
vintage pretty much um but it's still
around today still in production but you
know it has the advantage of
manual operation so you don't have to
rely on a mechanism and therefore
enough oomph to use the technical term
from the cartridge to actually cycle it
because you're doing all the cycling
with your
with your own muscles so all will always
have that advantage and that's something
you've brought up when we've talked
about the spaz 12 um when we've been
doing expert reacts the fact that this
is both pump action and semi-automatic
the pump action was for using those low
power loads but that's one of the
another one of the things that games
sort of dance around games quite often
go one of two ways and it's like no this
is a pump action shotgun this is a
semi-automatic shotgun yeah i guess
there's a spin-off of that hybrid
mechanism pump not that many shotguns do
pump or semi that gives you this very
blocky heavily vented forend that just
makes it look way more sci-fi and then
one with
a big internal is it a big interior
revolving drum
yeah of the striker this thing is
basically wind up so crank on the front
literally
comedy wind-up mechanism doesn't play a
song annoyingly no i won't wind it all
the way so interesting idea armstill but
maybe not that practical
again it's one of those weapons that i
think it's it's life in video games
so ridiculously outweighs its life
in the real world
over in the world of video games
shotguns exist on a huge spectrum but
rarely do the virtual versions match up
to how these weapons are used and how
they perform in reality while in the
real world combat shotguns have been
largely phased out they are still an
essential entry into any video game
arsenal one that taps into a specific
gameplay style and allows huge swings in
the balance of gameplay mechanics and
variety of play and yet somewhere along
the line they have become so
disconnected to their real world
counterparts much of this can be
distilled down to three main tropes for
most versions of a video game shotgun
range rate of fire and power
first of all their range of course the
sweet spot of the virtual shotgun is in
close quarters with shots of extreme
proximity resulting in a one-shot kill
where in some more extreme cases
reducing enemies to egypt mess
outside of spitting distance however
they largely leave enemies all but
mildly perturbed
their rate of fire is also frequently
tied to their shot power a good rule of
thumb is the faster a shotgun fires or
the more shells it holds the weaker
it'll be the classic double barrel being
the peak of power with minimal shots and
rapid fire magazine fed shotguns making
you work a little harder to add a kill
to your scoreboard
that power has been seen countless times
before in cinema where we've seen
cowboys and criminals alike thrown
across rooms from a single exaggerated
shot but that sense of devastating force
is very much tied to the identity of our
video game shotguns probably more than
any other video game type of gun i think
the shotgun has
been more of a parody certainly in early
first person shooters which then of
course set the trend
for later games doom 2 in particular
with the super shotgun the idea that a
shotgun is inherently a a spread of shot
which is true of course but normally you
design the gun or the choke on the end
of the gun and the ammunition to create
a certain size pattern at a certain
distance so in real life the shotgun is
much is much more finessed than we ever
seen in fiction it isn't just video
games the shotgun has long been the
stick the evil dead boomstick sums it up
it's this it's massive power
at close range and a spread of shot that
will in the most extreme cases kill
everyone in the room or something
however the amped up destruction that
comes with these shell slingers comes at
a price and it's the effective range and
sometimes the shot spread of the weapon
that is often the first thing to be
sacrificed for example here in gta 5 you
can see the pellets of my shotgun just
ceasing to exist over just a few meters
and then when the target comes back into
the game's allowed range suddenly
they're making contact again and if you
take a shotgun from 2019's call of duty
modern warfare let's say the model 680
this thing will do 208 damage to the
chest within 3 meters 101 damage between
5 to 50 meters but extend that to just
another meter more and the damage is now
one quarter of what it was up close
anything beyond that and the pellets
from your buckshot pretty much cease to
exist i remember back when modern
warfare was released back in 2019 there
was a lot of talk about the 725 being
overpowered and having a ridiculous
range now call of duty has always had at
least one overpowered shotgun in their
multiplayer looking at you model 1887s
and while these may actually be closer
to how the real world shotguns perform
they obviously upset the status quo of
our online lobbies and weapon balance so
for that their range is often pulled so
far back that longer distances you're
better off using harsh language against
your enemies
there's nothing more destructive than a
shotgun at close range but you can
really push the range out
by using a slug especially if you use
something like a rifled choke so
effectively a stick-on bit of barrel
that has rifling in it that just gives
enough of a twist to stabilize that slug
a bit better a slug being
essentially a giant bullet that fires
out of a shotgun usually a 12 gauge a
shotgun fight whether it's firing
buckshot or a slug is going to be
absolutely lethal
out to 100 meters or more you just might
struggle to hit what you're aiming at
variety and ammunition is something game
designers have tapped into in an effort
to make their in-game shotguns more
versatile and stand out from the crowd
slugs in particular are an ammo type
that have started to become much more
widely adopted into our video game
shotguns alongside the growing trend in
virtual weapon customization of course
there is also ammunition that has much
more of a life in video games than they
do in reality things like flechette
rounds flashbang shells or even the
over-the-top flame-spewing dragon's
breath ammo however it has often felt
that the addition of slugs to any video
game shotgun has been sort of a
band-aid fix to the issue of the
shotgun's range there's still the
trade-off between creating a pattern of
hits with buckshot and having a margin
of error as each piece of shot is spread
over your target as opposed to a
singular slug that may be more difficult
to make contact with but rewards you
with a lengthier range
there are games that walk the knife edge
of firearm realism however escape from
tarkov comes to mind where just a single
pellet of 8.5 millimeter buckshot
finding its way under your helmet can
send you back to the respawn screen even
from a pretty impressive range other
games that the shotgun exist is more of
a tool as a weapon games like insurgency
sandstorm where you can blow off hinges
or rainbow six siege where rounds are
used more to make a hole in drywall
rather than the enemy team
but other than a few edge case examples
the shotgun is a one-trick pony
admittedly it's a pony with a heck of a
kick to it but back in the real world
it's closer to a jack of all trades
so many games get the legendary shotgun
wrong and probably more often and more
frequently than any other virtual
firearm but i think we as players
have always known that and while other
things like suppressors scopes and
specific firearms are nitpicked and
critiqued something that i myself enjoy
doing we seem to give shotguns mostly a
free pass and continue to enjoy their
weird malleable video game versions more
so than the realistic ones the close
range punch of a shotgun encourages
players to get into the thick of intense
battles and firefights whether that's
getting cozy with a kaka demon in doom
eternal or storming a foxhole in
battlefield 5.
these up close and personal firefights
can create some of the most dynamic and
tense shootouts in video games knowing
that you can take down enemies the
single click or pull of a trigger but
also knowing that you're sowing enough
chaos and are in the depths of such
danger that you're just as likely to be
on the receiving end of that one hit
kill and while the tropes of its range
and the mysterious disappearing box shot
exists the fact that it's a
well-established element of video game
shotguns means that it can bring a
little balance to the arsenal of our
favorite shooters allowing players to
get that intense close quarters battle
where a single shot can fold an enemy in
half while dialing down the range in
which the punch can be really felt it
breaks the monotony of automatic fire in
our call of duty lobbies and what tools
are available to us when pushing an
objective in battlefield and in these
games and more they can be one of the
most satisfying weapons to use or at
least one of the most feared to come up
against many times i stormed the corners
of battlefield metro station shotgun in
hand and ready to fill my screen with
the feedback of enemy killed sure plenty
of times i'd run into that lone roamer
and i'm sure they were thinking why was
he trying to shoot me from there with
that as they easily outranged me with
rifle fire but the times i actually made
into those back lines and through
shallow after shell into the
unsuspecting enemy team will remain some
of the most fun i've had on that map and
i don't think those moments of gameplay
would be possible without the shotgun in
it specifically video game form
i think we can all agree that the
shotgun is one of the more iconic types
of video game gun and i think that's to
do with what it represents in terms of
destructive power i i always return to
the super shotgun in doom and just the
the the fact that you can take out an
enemy with one shot which
will require in a typical video game
will require something like a sniper
rifle or a shotgun uh sometimes that's
accompanied by graphic violence
sometimes less so but you always have
that visceral effect the sound effect
some sort of big flash a simulation of
recoil although obviously we can't
physically feel that
and then the impact on target of course
highly informed by films and tv
where the the the victim will fly back
you know several feet
and i think anyone that's seen a shotgun
used in popular culture whether that's a
western or more of an action movie kind
of wants to replicate that experience in
a video game or at least that's probably
where it got started
in the 300-ish year since its conception
the shotgun has become an icon of all
pop culture so many fantasy weapons
handheld flat cannons or laser-slinging
scatter guns can all be recognizable and
tap into the same feeling you get when
loading into levels of the pump action
or double barrel halo z184 on a scatter
shot battlefront 2's jawa ca 87 shock
blaster or the vile fleshy offering in
ebb software's upcoming horror scorn are
these shotguns
no but did they have some of that
shotgun dna and tap into the same
feeling that the real ones do
absolutely
for the most part i've always enjoyed
experiencing a little of the reality
behind these guns in my video games heck
that's half the reason i wanted to even
make loadout but with a shotgun is
concerned i think i enjoy the spectrum
that exists on a little bit more
it may be rarely represented in a way
that's even close to reality they may be
tough to balance and i'm sure that every
call of duty release will still launch
with that one rage inducing overpowered
shotgun but for all its faults and its
untapped features the humble video game
shotgun will never be any less super
thank you so much for watching this
week's episode of loadout if you enjoyed
please like the video and subscribe for
more and of course you can reach out to
me at a regular dave or let me know down
in the comments below what else you'd
like to see an episode on if you want
more video game firearms content you can
watch the previous series of this show
or check out our weekly series of expert
reacts where i show our friends at the
royal armouries a slew of guns to break
down and if you want to see an extended
video of our shotgun chat with jonathan
from this episode we'll have that up on
the channel next week until next time
i've been your host dave dewitt thank
you again for watching and i'll see you
in the next episode
[Music]
you